To Donald Trump's estranged niece, Mary L.
Trump has been working on a book which is
set to be published next week after having
the publishing date moved up.
The book is called Too Much and Never Enough
How My Family Created the World's Worst The
World's Most Dangerous Man.
So I want to talk about this because there's
really a lot going on here.
First of all, Mary Trump is the daughter of
Trump's brother, Fred Trump junior.
Fred Trump Junior is the brother who died
in 1981.
He was 42 at the time of a heart attack caused
by alcoholism.
This is told as the story, as the reason why
Trump doesn't drink or smoke cigarets.
The book was scheduled to be published further
down the line, but it was moved up to be expected
to be published next week.
There are a bunch of claims made about Donald
Trump in the book.
There have been attempts from Trump's family,
including Trump's brother, to stop the publication
of the book.
And then there are also the questions of whether
Marielle Trump's claims can be believed.
Now, Donald Trump's advisers and other people
around him have claimed that the book is riddled
with lies.
As you may know, if these lies are actually
lies, there is legal recourse, which is called
a libel lawsuit.
Some of the allegations include that Donald
Trump paid someone to take the essay Ts for
him when he was in high school, which was
how he got into the University of Pennsylvania.
Specifically, the claim is that he paid a
kid named Joe Shapiro to take the S.A.T. test
for him.
The book alleges that Donald Trump was verbally
abused by his father, Fred Trump.
The book actually says, quote, Casual dehumanization
of people was commonplace at the Trump dinner
table.
Both Trump and his brother were supposedly
abused by their dad.
But Trump maybe was less affected by it.
According to Marielle Trump, because he's
a, quote, sociopath.
Mary Trump claims that Trump's dad viewed
apologizing as a sign of weakness.
That's interesting because Donald Trump never
apologizes for anything.
She also says that lying was a way of life
in the Trump household, including as a way
to get around their dad disapproving of what
they were doing.
Again, Trump lies all the time and seems to
have no qualms whatsoever.
She tells the story of where Trump allegedly
went to see a movie the night that his brother
was sent to the hospital for that alcohol
induced heart attack that ultimately killed
him in 1981.
She claims Trump has been lying about being
religious.
Obviously, we knew that one.
And she says Trump has never actually gone
to church other than when there are cameras
there.
I actually don't care that Trump is not religious.
I did a segment a couple of years ago about
whether Donald Trump is the first atheist
president.
I don't care that Trump isn't religious.
What I care about is the fact that he lies
and panders by pretending to be religious
in order to appeal to evangelical voters.
Marielle Trump, who's also a clinical psychologist,
believes she's observed in Donald Trump all
nine criteria for narcissistic personality
disorder.
We've gone through that criteria.
That's also not hugely shocking or groundbreaking.
She mentions that he has essentially been
institutionalized for his entire adult life
and that he might not survive in the so-called
real world if he didn't have a business created
for him with daddy's money.
And I've made the same observation.
Donald Trump's behavior as president of the
United States, never mind as the guy running
the Trump organization in the real world in
a normal job, Trump would have been fired.
Trump would have a real difficulty in holding
a job.
So that's not a particularly shocking claim.
And.
Trump also believes that Donald Trump has
an undiagnosed learning disability, which
prevents him from processing information.
There are also claims that Trump's sister,
Maryanne Trump Barry, believes a lot of the
same stuff privately, but has chosen not to
say it publicly.
So listen.
On balance, I have to tell you, there isn't
that much that's newsworthy here or that is
new.
Really?
I mean, OK.
The claim about paying someone to take his
essay tees.
It's new and it's very specific being abused
by his dad.
That's a new claim, but it's not surprising.
I mean, people who treat others like crap
often were treated the same way growing up.
So when I look at Donald Trump and I look
at the bullying on social media, I look at
Trump making fun of I mean, everything, right.
Gold Star families, disabled reporters criticizing
Hispanic people talking about asshole.
You know, all of this stuff.
I see a damaged person who is repeating the
same thing they were exposed to.
These aren't excuses like he still is a bad
president and shouldn't be president.
Partially because of how he treats others.
But it's not groundbreaking to imagine that
people that treat others like crap were once
treated like crap themselves.
You know, the learning disability claim.
It's not surprising.
We've talked about is Trump's apparent lack
of attention, inability to remember and retain
stuff.
Verbal glitches, you know, all this different
Is there cognitive decline going on?
Could it be frontotemporal dementia, the side
effect of some medication, drug or whatever?
Right.
There's all these different ideas.
Learning disability could also explain a lot
of what we see with Donald Trump.
It's a reasonable speculation.
Specifically, it's new from the book.
But it's not altogether surprising.
So for me, what's most interesting about the
book is that based on what we've observed
of Donald Trump for the last three and a half
years as president and much longer in so far
as Trump has been a public figure.
It's not surprising what is alleged.
There's nothing in there where I would go,
wow, that's a really crazy claim.
That's way out of left field.
Trump cheats all the time and he believes
in buying his way to whatever he needs.
So Trump paying someone to take his essay
tease, if indeed he did it.
It's not really surprising the behavior we've
observed observed.
None of it is surprising.
And the picture that's painted by Marielle
Trump's book is the picture of an insecure
man who lacks knowledge and lacks cognitive
capacity, but is extremely narcissistic and
has very low morals.
And so he's willing to pay for what he needs
to pay.
He's willing to say whatever he thinks will
benefit, hit at that, benefit him at the time.
It's a very coherent and consistent picture
of the Donald Trump that we know.
We will ultimately see whether there are any
legal repercussions for what Trump Associates
are calling a book filled with lies.
And that's what I want to talk about next.